sources tell CBS News two more Americans
have been targeted in a mysterious sonic
attack overseas one of the victims
worked in the US Embassy in Uzbekistan
according to a source similar attacks
have been reported by American diplomats
in Cuba our sources say the latest
incident suggests Russia might be
involved in the attacks CBS News radio
Steve Dorsey broke the story in August
he's in Washington with the newest
information Steve good morning good
morning the incident in Uzbekistan was
reported in September and involves a
USAID officer and his wife a US
government source familiar with the
matter tell CBS News the two Americans
reported effects similar to the victims
in Cuba the husband and wife were flown
out of Tashkent Uzbekistan s capital by
the State Department for evaluation
according to a source their current
medical condition is unclear to u.s.
security sources say Russia may be
involved in that incident and in the
sonic attacks in Cuba the Russians have
the means the motive and the opportunity
foreign policy professor William Leo
gran says Russian President Vladimir
Putin has been trying to exert his
nation's influence abroad it seems that
this all began just around the same time
that President Obama expelled 35 Russian
diplomats because of Russia's
interference in our election victims of
the attacks in Cuba described hearing a
loud high-pitched sound in unusual
places often in their homes The
Associated Press obtained this recording
two dozen confirmed victims face a range
of health issues including hearing loss
and mild traumatic brain damage
in American tourists staying at the
hotel Capri in 2014 suspects he too
suffered a sonic attack and described
the sensation went from the tip of my
toes through my toes down through the
arch of my foot and and up to my ankles
and I could feel a little bit in my
fingertips when asked about the latest
case in Uzbekistan the State Department
told CBS News we ensure our personnel
are examined and receive appropriate
treatment following our report
spokeswoman Heather and our tweeted
there has been no incident in Uzbekistan
there was not an interest on the part of
the US government in having this go
public they don't know if something
happened just yet USAID an independent
federal agency that provides foreign
assistance referred all our questions to
the State Department the Russian
government has previously denied any
involvement in the attacks and has even
offered to assist the Cubans in their
investigation Gail all right thank you
very much Steve